we've got a real treat for you guys
especially all you Outlander fans out
there he's charming he's Scottish had
some no he did not pay me to write this
you guys he is joining us now in studio
mr. Richard Reagan he milk thanks for
$10 Richard you weren't lying you are
charming welcome welcome to eat see
thanks Wyatt no thank you for joining us
we've a lot to talk about obviously
today is a big day with the Golden Globe
nomination that's just amazing she's
incredible I mean the she carries the
weight of that sure almost
single-handedly and yeah the you know
the fact that she's nominated season
after season's test representing this
amazing show right yeah have you had a
chance to send her a texture you know I
would imagine her phone is blown up
today but no I haven't not yet I will do
um I only just found out like I better
know where to go okay I think you know
traveling around Bolivia I'm sure she's
somewhere celebrating right now we're
celebrating that you're here I mean for
season strong this show and we just
started I mean we still have a ways to
go this season there's been a lot of
developments with your character Roger
and Brianna I mean where do we even
begin I want to know knowing what you
know about the rest of the season what
can we expect with their relationship
what can we expect with their
relationship turmoil yeah drama conflict
love tears fighting they're still me at
the moment
Roger and Brianna think in each of them
refusing to come to the other safe
that's just how they are together as a
relationship I think it makes for a
wonderfully honest truthful relationship
and creates a lot of really great drama
will there ever be I know you can't give
away too much but I mean obviously
Outlander has already been renewed for
four seasons five and six will there
ever be a happy ending for them where
you use this turmoil is going to
continue to play out I think they have
moments of happiness okay I don't think
there's ever a happy ending
I think you know you never know we'll
wait and see what happens at the end of
season
for those definitely moments of
happiness together yes potentially for
them I don't know it would be too easy
for all fell into place right away right
some trauma do you want to keep that
ball rule and guessing what's gonna
happen with them we don't want to make
it too clear-cut yeah what do you hope
happens with those two as a fan of the
show what do I hold puppies well the
next step in the relationship I think
the next step in the relationship for
Roger sanity should be he should just
you know you should just maybe just let
it go
find any Scottish last sale don't maybe
start a farm a lot of drama between your
guys's relationship on the show on
camera but tell us a little bit about
your relationship with Sophie off-camera
do you guys pals or not yeah we work
very well together we click in a hat I
feel like we're at the ground run in
Sophie and I work well very much on the
same page with the characters were very
much have the same ideas and how we want
to present Roger I want to present
Brianna and how we want to present them
as a couple and one of the big things
for us is presenting that you know
staying true to that or honesty that the
truth of of our relationship it's a
complex thing it's a complicated thing
and I think we always have the same
ideas we chat a lot about how we want to
present certain scenes how we want to
play certain moments and so I feel like
we have a real a really strong bond
off-camera we have we have a lot of you
know a lot chemistry or horn handle yes
you know what yeah yeah I mean it helps
when you're on when you want to see a
patient you can have that collaborative
creative relationship with another act
that it helps a lot
I see what you're doing those more
intimate scenes too you know you can't I
kind of have to have that chemistry
right or at least some kind of
relationship with your coach yeah you
have to have that chemistry oh you just
pretend you guys laugh about that kind
of stuff too like I mean do you know
though see they're kind of intense yeah
well I mean the you know that they're
like any other scene you just want to
play you know you want to play the the
Bo of it you want to make sure that you
present it in a way that's gonna be
honest I suppose yeah how about you in
real life Richard like are you as
romantic as Roger is on the show would
you can see yourself a hopeless romantic
no I don't think I think Roger takes it
to another level I think he has
absolutely
we a hopeless romantic and bless him for
that it causes he gets sent to one or
two sticky situations because I've just
hoped passionate he has just how much he
wears his heart on his sleeve I think it
treks him up every now and again and I
think as we watch season four we'll see
maybe a bit more of that but it's one of
the things I love about or make you know
fact you know there are points we just
act and thanks about it we are you know
suffers the consequences further down
the line yeah but I don't think I'm I
don't think I'm quite on Rodgers level
yeah what would you say is the most
romantic thing we've ever done for
someone wow you're really you know I can
always spring it out on someone you know
in the middle of a really passionate
romantic kes whatever things just
perfect I could just hold that wait
there a moment and propose that that
seems that seems to what hopefully it
was better put you on the spot again but
you know the couples on this show me or
something else as a fan of the show
objectively who do you think is the
cutest couple
Breanna and Roger or clarín g.o Breanna
and Roger they are just adorable the two
of them are so you know they just the
salk well together sometimes I love I
just I love everything that they are I
love the way that are like you know an
elastic band are continuously coming
apart and springing back together again
explosively I just love how the
relationship ones folds I love the I
feel like it's somehow more relatable
and maybe that's because there are
modern couple as opposed to you know
Jimmy clear have been much more of the
past but yeah but then again I'm by yeah
we're not gonna answer that cuz
Outlander fans are really rabid right
gonna have their lot
a bit opinion on Richard in the intro
obviously we mentioned you're handsome
you're charming at but you're also
Scottish too so we you know Jeff right
Danny and I are curious and and we are
hoping that you would be willing to
teach us some kind of Scottish slang
well I've got a little et live Carla
feel like a prison man this is very
exciting
I'm gonna get you some Scottish slang
and you're gonna guess what it means
right what it means now I've got five of
them here and I would put money on you
getting one of them I feel like you're
doing well if you get that one all right
first one is yet act it you're at at it
like I say guitar tip you're going for
you're pestering you won't quit you're
talking nonsense okay and you get oaks
with no points competing okay here we go
okay the now when she's a bonny lass
she's a bony lass she has a bonny lass
oh it's okay give me an is it a good
thing about someone or a bad thing
oh it's definitely a good thing okay I
would say it could definitely a good
looker maybe yeah really I swear it and
cheat on that one oh I know okay cool
that's our one that you think you are
beautiful I mean I gave it away I gave
it away but one point you did okay
you're a chance' you're a chancer yeah
John so chancer like you it's that good
or bad
I feel like you're it's it's your what
oh it's what's the word that I'm looking
for
you're a tranche answer your risky one
just like yours taker oh that's that's
closed it so close it's not quite your s
Nicholas you're pushing your luck okay
so it is kind of like you know yeah
chancer your chain yeah you're pushing
your luck next one I like
a lot I say it often you're after your
heat yeah you're crazy you're like off
the rock what shoes
what's your heat yeah that what I came
to yes yes you're right you're yeah
you're better but at least I got watch
both your bit daft you know you're loud
this last ones be it was hojin Hatchin
it was horch and watch it I went out
last night I went to this club was a
good time he said that was such so it
was not yes it was fortunate last thing
obvious it was fortunate I could be move
okay oh it's crowded
it's busy but also has that double
meaning especially in class if he say it
was hojin that can refer to the ratio of
get older a certain venue yes she ghetto
girls oh sorry girl that's my bad knock
barking up the wrong check all right you
guys be sure to check out new episode of
Outlander
[Music]